welcome to another episode of shooting
star today we set our sights on pooza
home of the eSports champion turned ace
pilot diva idly to me at just 19 she's
become a national hero only last week
she risked her life but yet defending
the city from the Kishin Dominick's she
and the mecha squad took a few hits but
they pulled off another victory now
celebrating with some hard-earned glitz
and glamour
hey Hana shouldn't you be signing
autographs or something I wonder what
glitz and glamour tastes like hey why
aren't we on leave with the rest of the
squad I could use a little glitz and
glamour in my life you know it's
overrated pay on this this is where the
magic happens it's like how we used to
stay up late and work on your hover bike
you mean the one you wrecked really
you're still mad about that we won the
race
yeah and you almost killed yourself you
beat the Kishin they won't be back for
months you need a break I I can't
Hana
we barely won last time the enemy is out
there adapting and getting stronger the
rest of the squad the country they're
all counting on me if I make a mistake
in the Kishin get through us we lose
everything I need to finish the test
stop putting it all on yourself it's
okay to ask for help
I've got this really command says were
in the clear but hey what that can't be
right
it's too soon
fascinating
[Applause]
get to cover and wait for reinforcements
relax what a [ __ ]
[Music]
I can't stop this thing
[Music]
hey young I I need your help
really okay okay
the reactors getting unstable so you
can't stay too long the whole thing's
crazy if we don't do this okay
buy me some time
[Music]
the reactors going critical
[Music]
finished
[Music]
is still in shock after the recent
surprise attack incredibly thanks to
Dima no one was injured she stopped the
kitchen single-handedly and authorities
confirm she emerged without a scratch
she's currently enjoying some time off
to celebrate oh man
this time off is great isn't it what's
not to like there's delicious food and
drinks hmm and good friends the kind
that are always there for you when you
meet them most and seeing as I helped
save the city how about getting me on
the VIP list for one of those fancy
restaurants you always go to you know I
think you've been watching too many ha
Lovitz
you
[Music]